let's get back to hearing from the most
important people in our ecosystem the
audience we do take these calls for the
Friday show we do it via Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord and you can join what is called
The Waiting Lobby let's go to Alex from
Vienna now Alex is that Vienna Austria
or is it like you know Vienna Idaho or
so I don't know that Idaho really has a
Vienna but hey David thanks for taking
my call no it's Austria and Vienna
Austria yeah have you called in before
no it's my first time your first time
yeah well welcome yeah yeah so therefore
I'm a little bit nervous you're doing
great so far you've stated your name and
where you're calling from beautifully
and that's an auspicious beginning
perfect thank you so much so uh I have
an overall question
um how can we uh left prox left procs uh
improve because uh I think it was in the
United States that uh who was at Kevin
Newsom said something like that that the
leftists have to be more
um
and pop
populists
I don't remember Newsom saying more
populous would I remember Newsom saying
as Democrats on the left need to be more
ruthless we need to be unabashed we need
to you know but to to that was the gist
of his comments as I recall them
okay yeah something like that yeah and
in Austria we had a similar discussion I
mean it was six six or seven years ago
by uh Peter piltz he was from the queen
party and he tried this approach and it
was a uh overall a really good
um
person who tried to um
yeah as you can hear I'm nervous sorry
um you're doing great yeah so but so is
your is your question about whether this
is a good strategy yes and how to
improve listen
we
it's in the United States Democrats
aren't really doing this yet they're not
being ruthless to use Gavin newsom's
word
so I don't know if it's a good strategy
what I can tell you Alex is the status
quo is not working very well and even
though the left is right on so many
issues we're losing the discussion on a
lot of those issues when really we
should be winning because we actually
are on the right side of the issue so
it's very plausible that changing how we
talk about these issues is a great
starting point and I like the idea of
Gavin Newsom now will it work it's a
that's a predictive statement we have to
try it and see
but listen Okay what do we have to lose
at this point you know
yeah yeah for sure because uh the the
part is on the right uh you know the
ceiling the the the topics yes and and
manipulating them something like that
100 I mean we can do that as well in a
positive sense I would say yes uh and
and not just being in the defense all
the time that that's the impression I've
got in my own country yeah I am with you
and I hope to visit Austria soon I was
supposed to right before the start of
the pandemic and then we all know what
happened and I would like to get back I
want to go to Vienna I'd like to go to
Salzburg I want to be all over the
country
and great okay yeah I might be again in
the States this year no well then I'll
miss you I guess that's too bad all
right Alex from Vienna thank you for the
call thank you thank you very very good
did an excellent job excellent job